Samsung s23 Ultra versus iPhone 14 pro
Max which one is the king of smartphones
well today we're going to compare
everything from the design to the
displays speakers performance cameras
and more now I have to say I was
surprised by this new Samsung once I
took it out of the box now let me take
off my case Q case here to show you guys
the differences we got the flat sides
and the rounded corners but the Samsung
even though it looks the same online
they've actually changed the feeling of
the phone in your hand the screen no
longer curves as far to the side and
these sides are actually flat with a
little bit of curve on the front and the
back just like the rumors for the
upcoming iPhone 15 Pro Maxes and this
thing feels amazing in the hand better
than the iPhone it's kind of The Best of
Both Worlds flatten the sides plus a
little bit of curve to make it feel
thinner when it is actually a little bit
thicker than the previous one I like
that the top is completely flat so
overall I would have to give the design
win to Samsung now I do wish that this
red looked a lot more red I'm not a fan
of it in person and I do like the
iPhone's camera design a little bit
better now with that as far as the
cameras these things gotten bigger this
year because we have a 200 megapixel
camera 108 was already crazy now of
course we're gonna do a blind camera
comparison including the new pixel 7 Pro
those are always a ton of fun so make
sure you guys are subscribed and with
that I'm also going to do another one
comparing the s23 ultra against the s22
and S21 Ultra to see if there's really
that big of a difference so enable those
notifications now the Samsung has their
Infamous S Pen which is really sweet
that it's built into the phone itself if
you love to draw or take notes that is a
huge win but the iPhone has Mac safe
which means you can use various
accessories like the stand powers that
from our partners moft this is a TP set
that includes my favorite magsafe wallet
and their magnetic power bank which all
snap together so you can use both of
them at the same time and it could
support your phone both in landscape and
portrait mode now the Samsung doesn't
come with Mac safe but thankfully mop
has a solution with their magnetic ring
sticker that you can get with the wallet
and Bam we have macsafe on the s23 ultra
they also have their adjustable phone
lanyard which is very versatile has a
bunch of cool features like a quick
disconnect a swivel hook and you can
wear it around the neck or crossbody
style it makes it easy to handle big
phones like the Samsung or the 14 pro
Max and you can be totally hands-free
for your daily commute it's the first
Lane you're specifically designed to be
neutral minimalist for men and it's
really high quality using metal Parts
with quick disconnects so go ahead and
check out the links to all of those
items down in the description below now
inside this Samsung has a 5 000 milliamp
hour battery compared to about 4300 in
the iPhone and you could charge it at 45
watts compared to 27. now as far as
wireless charging they made a change
this year and QI charging only supports
10 watts now instead of 15 and to get
the full 15 you have to use a new
protocol with a different charger but
you have a similar thing with the iPhone
using Apple's proprietary Maxi charging
now as far as the actual battery life
Samsung has high claims but we've seen
time and time again even though it has a
bigger battery the iPhone beats it out
in terms of real world battery life now
as far as the displays both of these are
gorgeous high resolution they get nice
and bright now the iPhone is rated up to
2 000 nits compared to 1750 but those
Peaks will only happen in super bright
sun outside now if we manually max out
the brightness the iPhone is still
brighter even if we enable the extra
brightness mode now taking a look at HDR
video a lot of times they look almost
identical but the iPhone does have more
Peak brightness in the highlights along
with a little bit more detail in those
bright spots so the iPhone does take the
win here but I will say if you're
watching full screen video I love that
the Samsung just has that little cutout
compared to the dynamic Island which is
really big and it's way more distracting
of course that's because a Samsung
mainly relies on its under display
fingerprint sensor whereas the iPhone
uses all that space for face ID now
Samsung has been doing a killer job with
their speakers in their phone so let's
do a speaker comparison and let's hear
which phone sounds better
[Music]
thank you
let me know which one sounded better to
you they both sound good the iPhone
sounds a bit more spatial where the
sound is evenly distributed whereas the
Samsung might have slightly higher
brights or brighter brights but a bit
less bass but I want to hear your guys's
opinion and now let's get into
performance now we have geekbench 5
opened up right here but they actually
released geekbench 6 which is more
accurate more up-to-date for modern
phones we're going to show you guys both
now right here we can see the iPhone has
six gigs compared to 12 gigs on the
Samsung and we have Apple's a16 bionic
compared to the new Snapdragon 8 Gen 2
so let's go ahead and run our Benchmark
all right we have our scores in as far
as single core the iPhone beats out the
Samsung by 19 and in multi-core the
Samsung is getting close but the iPhone
is still 10 faster now let's remember
those scores and we're gonna open
geekbench six we're gonna run that same
same CPU Benchmark but with this new
test wow this one's taking a lot longer
to run and the iPhone got done first all
right wow guys that is a bigger
difference now the Creed as a geekbench
said this is more realistic inaccurate
and now instead of a 19 gain for the 14
pro Max we have a 30 gain and instead of
10 for multi-core we have a 21 gain in
favor of the iPhone that is a big
difference now before the next test I've
got to talk about the best magsafe
iPhone case I've ever seen the magic
stand case from our partner K school not
only is it surprisingly slim and durable
but it comes with a very strong 48
Magnet Max a Fring that actually doubles
as a stand just pull out the ring to use
it as a finger grip or as a stand
watching videos at any angle between 40
and 120 degrees and the best part is
that it folds back completely flush with
the case so you could still use it with
your magsafe chargers and accessories so
check out the link and all of the
discount info in the video description
below now with the Snapdragon 8 Gen 2 we
also have a better graphics processor
we're going to switch over to Vulcan
here we're going to be using metal for
the iPhone and let's compare the
graphics performance alright so the s23
has a super low score but it says that
one or more of the workloads have failed
so I'm going to go back and I'm going to
try this out with opencl so this time it
did finish properly but the iPhone has
over doubled the score for compute tasks
so maybe there are still some bugs or
something that have to be fixed so as
far as compute we know the iPhone is
faster but not by how much so now we're
gonna open 3dmark Wildlife extreme we're
gonna run the unlimited mode so I'm
going to select that right here that way
there's no difference in resolutions
it's off screen and let's see how these
compare in terms of gaming interestingly
the iPhone's taking longer to load up
this game so maybe the Samsung has
really fast storage and look at that the
iPhone just got smoked we have 17.9
frames per second compared to
22.7 the Samsung gets 29 better frames
per second now we have heard that the
Samsung gets really hot and then
dramatically slows down so it can't
maintain this now we do want to test
that ourselves so we will be doing a
full-on gaming comparison video and
testing throttling and heat so if you
guys want to see that make sure you guys
are subscribed and now let's talk about
these cameras of course a Samsung is now
doing 200 megapixels which is insane now
the iPhone's 48 megapixels already
looked more detailed than the s22 ultra
is 108. here's a photo side by side you
guys let us know which one looks better
now it also has a 3x lens to match up
with the iPhone and they both have Ultra
wide lenses now one of the weird things
is that Samsung seems to have downgraded
the selfie camera it used to be 40
megapixels and it looked better than the
iPhone better than the pixel looked
amazing here's a shot from both of them
you guys take a look and let me know
which one looks better to you and
remember we're gonna do our blind
unbiased camera comparison so we'll be
able to choose which one looks better
without knowing which one is which and
with that we're going to compare this 10
megapixel to the previous 40 on s22 as
well as the S21 to see if it's gotten
better or worse now the last thing I
want to mention that's cool is that you
don't have to shoot the whole 200
megapixel if I go into camera mode here
select this button I can select the full
200 or I could select 50 or I can do the
down sampled one which goes from 200
down to 12 so that is a nice option so
with all that said which phone is the
king of Flagship phones well I'll be
honest it is very very tough some people
were really disappointed with the new
Samsung but using it holding it in the
hand it does seem like a decent update
but it definitely is iterative it's not
a big change at all people who say
iPhone barely makes any changes well
with this one we got a ton of updates
and it was a really really nice upgrade
so I want to hear from you guys which
phone do you think is the best flagship
phone let me know down in the comment
section below and we're going to be
running some more tests using these
phones to figure that out for ourselves
in our upcoming videos go ahead and
click that Circle above to subscribe
check out one of those great videos
right over there the spin Max and I'll
see you in the next one
foreign